THE HORRIFIC CONDITIONS HE CAME
BACK IN.
OBVIOUSLY THE TRAGEDY.
GOOD NEWS TONIGHT, THANKS, ED.
ACCORDING TO A RELEASE FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THAT WOULD BE
MIKE POMPEO STATE DEPARTMENT,
THE THREE FREED HOSTAGES HAVE
ISSUED A STATEMENT WRITING "WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT, TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, TO SECRETARY
POMPEO AND THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR BRINGING US
HOME.
WE THANK GOD AND ALL OUR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS WHO PRAYED
FOR US AND FOR OUR RETURN.
GOD BLESS AMERICA, THE GREATEST
NATION IN THE WORLD."
CAN'T WAIT FOR THEM TO LAND.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTIONS
ALL THE BIG DEVELOPMENT'S TODAY,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT, FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURE DISCHARGES, DR. SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
RETIRED CIA INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER, WE WELCOME HIM TO THE
FOX FAMILY.
OF COURSE, HE'S BEEN IN A LOT.
DANIEL HOFFMAN.
DR. GORKA, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
HOSTAGES ARE FREE.
IT TOOK A MILITARY PRESENCE.
IT TOOK THE PRESIDENT TAUNTING
KIM JONG UN.
IT TOOK SANCTIONS, BUT IT
WORKED.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT BROUGHT IN
$150 BILLION IN CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCIES AND CARGO PLANES TO